Barry's a country was opened in 19
million population in a country with a
long history,
very rich culture,
and unfortunately some of the production
practices and enormous affect women and
negatively in the practice of Lfr,
which is a abducting girls for marriage,
is one of the harmful practices that
affect other physical and mental,
uh,
as with less social economic lives of
women in Ethiopia.
Mm,
okay.
I heard about the story on the radio.
Uh,
uh,
I was,
I was in a car with a driver and we were
listening to radio and,
uh,
the,
there was a media coverage about 14
years old girls being abducted and raped
and killing her would be husband.
So as soon as I,
um,
learned about story,
I immediately thought that we should be
going to this place which is 300
kilometers outside our discipline,
our where we work and we should be able
to defend the code.
I thought about this because,
uh,
I believe that,
we should save her life because she was
a facing like a life sentence.
And secondly,
also,
I knew that this is going to be a big
case precedent setting case,
which we'll see we could use for public
education to,
uh,
you know,
it has the dialogue and the conversation
around,
um,
abduction around that
onto and asked you kind of got him
uncle.
For some people,
especially people living in the West is
completely outside their experience.
Uh,
in that sense,
it's really educate,
educate people or uh,
you know,
uh,
how women live in the other part of the
world lit.
Secondly,
it's also a call to action.
Uh,
I believe,
um,
education been a women's rights
organizations and,
uh,
um,
government and then government and
institutions whose mandate focus on
gender equality,
uh,
would like to use this field to,
for advocacy for a ligand reform and to
sort of enhance and accelerate,
um,
uh,
programs,
towards,
uh,
especially,
fighting child marriage around the
world.
Like that's my hope.
Getting Angelina Jolie was quite
helpful.
The movie,
the content history,
uh,
the presentation is fantastic,
but her are going to be the executive
producer of really give,
took it to another label,
to another height.
And,
uh,
I think that's what was kind of
a highlight,
but I will
path.
I'm
good.
I'm on Jay and Martha,
I think this film is quite educational
because it does not necessarily judge
the community.
It does not necessarily,
uh,
you know,
sort of point the finger desert
community,
it sort of
shows,
you know,
where the thinking comes from.
It's sort of a mixture you to have a
conversation with yourself because it
makes,
it,
makes you,
it's not that easy a sort of a sin,
uh,
because this people,
they have lived half lived was a
practitioner for a number of years and
that's what they know.
That's what they believe from time to
time,
we need to go back to the drawing board
and we need to have a real conversation
on why these things are happening.
It's not enough to say,
well,
it's a culture where it's a tradition we
need to discuss about,
unpack and to discuss about why this is
happening.